[Musique]
c'est une liste de
7754 noms des enfants que les autorités
ukrainiennes réclament à celle de Moscou
des mineurs restés dans les territoires
conquis par les Russes et déplacés
parfois en Russie
voici le récit de 2 de ces destins
que Sacha lopane un village occupé par
les Russes en février et repris il y a
deux semaines
c'est là que vivent Yuri Tatiana et leur
fille dont ils n'ont plus de nouvelles
fin août Polina ne vend est monté dans
un autobus à destination de la Russie
avec très autre enfant un voyage
organisé par la mairie prorus
on l'a embrassé on lui a fait un câlin
je lui ai dit profite bien en fait la
mairie emmène les enfants en colonie de
vacances sur la mer Noire elle a
convaincu ses parents de confier Paulina
car le village est bombardé
on a accepté pour que notre fille soit
en sécurité
un enfant a été mort dans notre rue une
femme aussi
on pensait bien faire
les enfants auraient dû rentrer
mi-septembre mais avec le village repris
la frontière russe s'est refermée sur la
famille
Nathalie Ahmed la voisine a aussi envoyé
sa fille en colonie et elle a peur
désormais que les Russes refusent de lui
rendre son enfant comment elle s'appelle
Karina elle a 13 ans la mère nous montre
le journal prorus qui vante la colonie
de vacances sur la mer Noire un journal
de propagande
vous pensez que les Russes veulent
garder les enfants
oui oui
ukrainiennes pour rester on leur dit que
l'Ukraine ne les veut plus on leur
propose des logements si j'y vais je ne
pourrais pas revenir avec ma fille
Nathalie Ahmed n'a pas parlé avec Karina
depuis son départ la mairie n'a jamais
donné l'adresse du camp ou même un
numéro de téléphone
madame je ne peux pas lui parler je ne
peux pas l'appeler je ne peux pas lui
dire on va venir te chercher attends un
peu
j'ai peur
de l'angoisse et un sentiment coupable
pour cette mère
la police ukrainienne est venue voir les
familles de Polina et Karina pour
recueillir le récit réclamer le retour
des enfants
depuis le début de la guerre 56 mineurs
ont pu être rapatriés de territoires
occupés ou de Russie en Ukraine